other American detainees please do all
you can to bring us home
we never forgot about Brittany we've not
forgotten about Paul Whalen who's been
unjustly detained in Russia for years
this was not a choice of which American
to bring home
we brought home Trevor Reed when we had
a chance earlier this year
sadly for totally illegitimate reasons
Russia is treating Paul's case
differently than Britney's and while we
have not yet succeeded in securing
Paul's release we are not giving up we
will never give up we remain in close
touch with Paul's family the wheel and
family and my thoughts and prayers are
with them today they have to have such
mixed emotions today and will keep
negotiating in good faith for Paul's
release I guarantee that I say that to
the family I guarantee you
I urge Russia to do the same to ensure
that Paul's health and you and your main
treatment are maintained until we are
able to bring him home I don't want any
American to sit wrongfully detained and
one extra day if we can bring that
person home my Administration has now
brought home dozens of Americans who are
wrongfully detained are held hostages
abroad many of whom had been held since
before I took office and today we also
remember the other Americans that are
being held hostage and wrongfully
detained in Russia or anywhere else in
the world
reuniting this Americans with their
loved ones remains a priority a priority
for my administration every person in my
Administration involved in this we're
going to continue to work to bring home
every American who continues to endure
such an injustice
we also want to prevent any more
American families from suffering this
pain and separation
am I strongly urge I strongly urge all
Americans to take precautions including
reviewing the state Department's travel
advisories before they travel overseas
which now includes warnings about the
risk of being wrongfully detained by a
foreign government
make no mistake about it this work is
not easy negotiations are always
difficult there are never any guarantees
but it's my job as president United
States to make the hard calls and
protect American citizens everywhere in
the world anywhere in the world and I'm
proud that today we have made one more
family whole again
so welcome home Brittany and now I'd
like to invite shirelle to say a few
words to all of course she's not excited
at all about this shirelle it's all
yours kiddo congratulations again thank
you
so over the last nine months you all
have been
um
so privy to one of the darkest moments
of my life and so today I'm just
standing here overwhelmed with the
emotions but the most important emotion
that I have right now is just sincere
gratitude for President Biden and his
entire Administration
he just mentioned this work is not easy
and it has not been there's been so many
hands involved and so I'd like to take a
moment to just specifically mention a
few vice president Harris secretary
blinken Jake Sullivan just gilser from
the National Security Council Roger
Carlson and Fletcher shown from the
hostage invoice office
a special thank you to Governor
Richardson and Vicki the Mercury players
the wmb PA for your advocacy and also
you guys may not know this but my family
has been tremendously supported by the
Washington Agency BG's agent
um Lindsay kolis has just been amazing
for me and my family throughout this
process so today my family is whole but
as you all are aware there's so many
other families who are not whole and so
BG's not here to say this but I will
gladly speak on her behalf and say that
BG and I will remain committed to the
work of getting every American Home
including Paul whose family is in our
hearts today as we celebrate BG being
home we do understand that there are
still people out here who are enduring
what I endured the last nine months of
missing tremendously their loved ones so
thank you everybody for your support and
today it's just a happy day for me and
my family so I'm going to smile right
now
um thank you
thank you thank you all very much
when will Brittany be back in the U.S
what has Russia Mr president President
Biden speaking there along with Brittany
greiner's wife uh shirelle reacting to
that news that Brittany Greiner has been
released
from U.S custody
let's bring in our Moscow correspondent
uh Diana magnet now who's standing by
for us and there was much uh discussion
in that press conference as well as all
the happy remarks about Brittany
greiner's release of course uh reference
as well to Paul Whelan who hasn't been
released from Russian custody in a
senior U.S official has told NBC news or
U.S Partners Diana that they tried
everything they could to get Paul
Wheeling out but they're treating him
very differently
yes it was interesting to hear the U.S
president say that the Russians consider
um Paul's case somehow uh different he's
in jail on Espionage charges and the
sentence is an extremely long one he's
served almost four years now this will
be his fourth Christmas without his
family
um and clearly uh from the American
point of view
um the Russians were the ones who
refused to countenance uh handing over
Paul too but it was quite heartwarming
to hear
um both uh the U.S president and in fact
Charelle Brittany Grinder's wife saying
you know we will not uh give up on
trying to secure Paul Whelan's release
Joe Biden saying that a number of times
I guarantee you that we will continue
doing everything in our power to get
Paul Whelan out
um and David his brother who's run this
impressive campaign really ever since
Paul was in prison nearly four years ago
a has sent out an email
saying you know we are so pleased that
Brittany Greiner has been released this
is wonderful for us and we do not
begrudge the moment at all but of course
remember
um all the efforts that everyone is
putting in and please do not forget
about Paul which you can really
understand
um but it is it is a an amazing moment
really that that
um Russia and America have managed to
negotiate this exchange we're hearing
from Russia's human rights commissioner
that the Abu Dhabi airport was chosen
because it was an easy Logistics
exchange Point she said that all the um
all the uh praise for this operation
should go to the Russian uh special
secret Services well I'm sure American
secret services and all of those who
were thanked by cherelle Brittany
greiner's wife all played a role in this
exchange the second big prisoner
exchange this year really but Brittany
Greiner was you know she's a huge star
in America and basketball fans all
around the world so it was a very high
profile case to see her imprisoned for I
suppose a nine and a half year sentence
um and now just a few months later for
the Americans to have orchestrated uh
her release but as Joe Biden said there
you know this is wonderful um we're so
glad she's coming home but we will not
forget about other Americans
unreasonably detained around the world
and especially Paul Whelan here in
Russia
okay Diana for now thank you and we will
bring you more on that breaking news
throughout the day here on Sky News to
stay across the channel for that
and now Prince Harry has described what
he calls a Feeding Frenzy surrounding
his relationship with Megan with the
duchess saying the Press would always
find a way to destroy her in the first
three episodes of their Netflix
documentary Megan says she received
death threats after their relationship
became public knowledge the couple also
recount how members of the royal family
said Megan should not receive protection
or special treatment well joining me now
is broadcaster afwa Hagen thank you very
much indeed for joining us um I think
it's very interesting isn't it Meghan
markle's comment that she believed no
matter what she did the media was still
going to find a way to destroy her
what's your reaction to that because
indeed the media when they first got
together seemed very very excited about
their relationship
yes and those comments made right at the
beginning of episode one actually but
then it became clear through you know
all the stories that you know came from
sources that were just making things up
to the headlines with racial undertones
like Harry's girl is Straight Out of
Compton that certain British tabloids
were not being fair towards uh Megan and
yes there was this kind of discourse and
Harry was told by the palace that you
know other wives and girlfriends have
had to go through the same thing it's
particularly bad with women but of
course there was a racial element to
this as well and Harry said he was quite
naive and I think Megan was as well you
know she didn't realize
um how much the British press would take
on bridge by her being a biracial woman
and how much that would have an effect
on the reporting about her
and do you think that racism was at the
heart of the main problems uh that Harry
and Megan had with the with the
institution and with the media
I think definitely racism and classism
plays a huge part in the way that she
was portrayed and in the issues that
they certainly had with the British
press I think there was also cultural
differences the fact that she was
American the fact that she was an
actress the fact that she was a divorcee
but the fact that she was black the fact
that she was biracial plays a huge part
in that and plays a huge part in lots of
the ways in which she was reported about
it and the stories that were written
about her in the way that she was pitted
against other female members of the
royal family definitely race plays a
huge part in that
where do you think this is all going to
end do you think this is just going to
make the rift with the royal family even
worse or do you think it is somehow
still reconcilable
that's a really good question isn't it I
think after these three episodes which
actually were really mostly about their
Love Story how they got together how the
relationship played out you know after
these three episodes I think definitely
reconciliation could be on the cards if
that's what either side wants but we
haven't seen four five and six the next
three episodes which are going to be at
this time next week we don't know what
will be in there perhaps it depends on
that but maybe we might get Bombshells
we might get things that we haven't had
before and these three episodes we
weren't really being told anything new
and they definitely were not highly
critical of the royal family so perhaps
if episodes four five and six are
differently if that plays out
differently then perhaps it may be a
different story so I think it remains to
be seen ask me this time next week
okay afwa Hagen we will have to leave it
there thank you so much for joining us
today thank you
now coming up at around two o'clock this
afternoon the former U.S spy who killed
the British teenager Harry Dunn when
driving on the wrong side of the road in
northamptonshire three years ago is to
be sentenced at the Old Bailey now we'll
be bringing you full coverage of that
sentencing this afternoon here on Sky
News and joining me is at the legal
commentator Joshua Rosenberg who'll be
with us throughout this afternoon thank
you very much indeed for joining us what
do you make of this sentencing of course
answer kulas hasn't been in the country
let alone the courtroom uh during this
whole legal process so what really can
we expect to come from today's
sentencing
it will be very much like an ordinary
case except as you say the defendant is
not in court she'll be on a video link
she's never been in court in the United
Kingdom I can't think of a case like
that although judges have told me that
there have been cases uh where the
defendant has not attended so she will
be on a video link presumably from her
lawyer's office in Washington DC and she
will see the judge the judge will see
her and we will see the judge when the
judge pass his sentence after hearing
from the prosecuting and defense lawyers
we won't see answerculus all we'll see
is the judge but we will see the judge
speaking direct to answer coolers just
as answer coolis will be watching on a
screen and we will hear the sentence
that the judge Mrs Justice Chima grabbed
passes for the offense of answer kulis
admitted which is causing the death of
19 year old Harry Dunn by careless
driving
there is a maximum sentence of five
years in prison for death by dangerous
driving if a custodial sentence were to
be issued by the judge today what
chances are there that answer kulas
would ever serve even one day in prison
given that the U.S government refused to
travel to the UK for this for this
process there's no way in which the
sentence whatever it is today can be
enforced unless and circulus is willing
to come to the United Kingdom and the US
government has made it very clear that
they won't allow her to do that if
however she is given a community
sentence which does seem the most likely
because although five years is the
maximum for causing death by careless
driving it is possible to have a
non-custodial sentence
if there are no aggravating
circumstances making the offense more
serious if this community penalty is
imposed then it's something that we know
because ansukulus's lawyer told me last
year we know this is something that she
would like to carry out if she possibly
can in the United States now this
wouldn't be fulfilling the Court's order
but it would be doing the next best
thing whatever it may be unpaid work or
work in the community something to make
amends
and and the fact that answer kulas left
the UK without Harry Dunn's family
knowing claiming diplomatic immunity it
what do you make of that and how that
all played out she was fully entitled to
the U.S embassy checked with the foreign
Commonwealth office and they accepted
that because of a loophole because
something was overlooked she was fully
entitled to diplomatic immunity even
though her husband would not have been
if it was if it had been his car that
had been involved that had been involved
in this tragic accident so she was not
only entitled to leave the country in
the circumstances where she wasn't going
to be prosecuted
she would have been expected to leave
the country this being the next best
thing to putting her on trial as she
waited until she was told this and the
foreign office allowed her to go before
telling Harry Don's family something for
which then foreign secretary uh Dominic
Robb I apologize and explained she was
certainly allowed to go and she went
lawfully
a Joshua Rosenberg thank you very much
indeed for joining us we'll speak to you
later on
you're watching Sky News at one coming
up in a few moments at two o'clock the
Dunn family have arrived at the old
bayley and we will be bringing you the
sentencing of answer kulas which is
happening uh from two o'clock this
afternoon just a few minutes time stay
across Sky News for the coverage
[Music]